dernière audition plière sur la
thématique de la santé des femmes au
travail nous aurons encore quelques
auditions des rapporteurs mais nous
avons souhaité clore notre cycle
d'audition plénière en entendant des
représentants des partenaires sociaux en
effet les organisations syndicales et
patronales ont un rôle central à jouer
sur ces sujets elles sont représentées
au sein de la commission des accidents
du travail maladie professionnelle et du
Conseil d'orientation des conditions de
travail et en son sein du Comité
national de prévention et de santé au
travail nous souhaitons connaître leur
recommandation et propositions d'action
face aux différentes problématiques qui
ont émergé au cours de nos auditions
les travaux à cette fin nous accueillons
pour la CGT madame Frédéric Barlette
elle est pas là pardon excusez-moi donc
après j'avais pas recoclé les noms ok
donc pour le Medef madame Diane de
Perroy
a très bien voilà donc quand même c'est
ce que je me disais tout à l'heure
j'avais vu des noms quand même Céline
Verzeletti voilà et là pour la CGT donc
et donc bienvenue madame voilà donc
Monsieur Olivier Perrot
rapporteur Laurence Cohen Annick
Jacquemet Marie-Pierre Richer et
Laurence Rossignol certaines vont nous
rejoindre dans quelques instants
normalement et donc nous avons la
présence de Marie-Pierre Monnier qui est
avec nous ce matin sénatrice de la
délégation très engagée aussi sur ces
sujets donc je le disais depuis six mois
nous auditionnons et nous avons été
adressé des constats quatre constats
principaux tout d'abord un déficit
d'approche jean-ré en matière de santé
au travail cette approche est en
pourtant prévue depuis la loi du 4 août
2014 au sein du document d'évaluation
des risques professionnels deuxièmement
une sous-estimation des risques
professionnels auxquelles les femmes
sont exposées ainsi qu'une
sous-déclaration des maladies
professionnelles plus particulièrement
dans les secteurs après dominance
féminine TMS risque psychosociaux cancer
professionnelle et j'en passe
en troisièmement une exposition
différenciée des femmes et des hommes au
risque professionnel y compris au sein
de même profession et enfin conséquence
de tout ce qui précède à
sous-développement des politiques de
prévention dédiées au secteur après
dominance féminine et à la santé des
femmes donc nous souhaitons vous
entendre sur ces différents sujets et
surtout connaître vos recommandations
afin d'améliorer la prise en compte des
risques professionnels affectant
principalement les femmes et de
développer des politiques de prévention
dans le milieu professionnel en faveur
de la santé des femmes voilà Laurence
Rossignol rapporteur bienvenue nous
souhaitons également recueillir vos avis
sur quelques sujets spécifiques celui de
l'impact du travail de nuit sur le
cancer du sein les études
épidémiologiques indiquent que le
travail de nuit augmente de près de 30%
le risque du cancer du sein
envisagez-vous la création d'un tableau
de maladies professionnelles pour le
cancer du sein ou en est-on la création
d'un tel tableau pour le cancer de
l'ovaire qui a été annoncé du fait des
liens avérés entre exposition à
l'amiante et cancer de l'ovaire celui le
sujet aussi spécifique du congé
menstruel adopté par le Parlement
espagnol en février dernier et instauré
dans quelques structures comme le groupe
Carrefour ou la commune de Saint-Ouen
alors que 10% des femmes souffrent
d'endométriose cette solution vous
semble-t-elle efficace quels alternatifs
proposez-vous et enfin celui du
caractère systémique des violences
sexistes et sexuelles au travail et de
leur impact sur la santé des femmes
ainsi que le défaut de prévention
primaire dans ce domaine je laisse dès à
présent la parole représentant de la CGT
c'est l'universeletti et Olivier
Perrault je vous cède la parole et
bienvenue à notre collègue rapporteur
Laurence Rossignol
il faut brancher le micro à gauche
comme ça c'est bon donc merci pour
l'invitation bonjour à toutes et à tous
juste faire donc une petite introduction
puis après
mon camarade
précisera ou répondra aux questions
qu'il faut donc déjà pour un
introduction mais comme vous avez pu le
dire
en effet de nombreuses études et de
donner donc de la branche à de la
sécurité sociale mettre en effet en
évidence une augmentation sensible des
accidents de travail et des maladies
professionnelles touchant les femmes
donc ceci est lié au poste qu'elles
occupent en effet et à l'absence de
prise en compte de certaines
spécificités féminines alors comme vous
l'avez cité aussi les pathologies dont
elles sont le plus souvent victimes sont
les troubles musculo-squelettiques les
troubles psychosociaux et risquent
organiserationnel pardon et les cancers
professionnels entre autres mais c'est
vraiment donc les pathologies dont elles
sont le plus souvent victimes
alors la CGT elle fait des propositions
et aussi très souvent des rappels donc à
la loi puisque en effet normalement le
document unique d'évaluation des risques
professionnels vous l'avez indiqué doit
être jeanré c'est une obligation depuis
2014 et en effet ne l'est pas pour la
très grande majorité des lieux de
travail que ça soit d'ailleurs du public
ou du privé ça c'est un vrai
problématique et c'est important
peu de contrôle du coup aussi et donc
forcément ceci explique cela et de
sanctions prévues pour remédier à cette
situation comme sur de nombreux sujets
un lien à la santé la sécurité au
travail les contrôles et les sanctions
sont insuffisantes
alors même qu'on le sait c'est une
justement des conditions nécessaires
pour que la loi soit véritablement
appliquée donc ce manque de contrôle et
souvent dû à un manque d'effectif dans
les dread c'est dans les structures type
CARSAT donc et aussi nous en profitons
bien évidemment pour rappeler que nous
nous demandons à nouveau que il y a un
rôle donc des CHSCT que ça puisse être
revu donc les CHSCT les élus du
personnel qui siègent pourrait aussi
donc par des prérogatives bien
évidemment renouvelés remédier à un
certain nombre de carences et la remise
en place donc de ces CHSCT devient une
nécessité incontournable
concernant le travail de nuit et le
cancer du sein donc
là c'est pareil des choses à revoir et à
voir donc la récente reconnaissance par
pour une infirmière de nuit pendant 28
ans par le comité régional de
reconnaissance des maladies
professionnelles de la région Grand Est
une première avancée mais ce système
complémentaire de réparation des
maladies dites à caractère
professionnelle nécessite que la victime
apporte des éléments à ce comité et
qu'il conclut ou pas d'ailleurs à un
lien direct entre le travail et la
maladie donc pour répondre à votre
question un tableau de maladie
professionnelle et donc indispensable à
créer pour que les victimes bénéficient
de la présomption d'origine
le coq et sa commission spécialisée
numéro 4 où sont représentés donc les
organisations syndicales rencontrent une
opposition patronale forte pour la
création de ce tableau facilitateur
pourtant de la reconnaissance en maladie
professionnelle
même problématique concernant de
nombreux risques psychosociaux ou
qu'elles sont exposées justement les
femmes psychot traumatisme des lieux
insectices et sexuels pression
hiérarchique non reconnaissance des
emplois prédominance féminines risquent
organisationnel pas de tableau aux
maladies professionnelles et donc
difficultés de faire reconnaître pour
donc les mêmes raisons si tu es
précédemment
il y a un effet vous l'avez dit aussi me
semble-t-il une sous-estimation des
risques professionnels donc cette
sous-estimation s'explique entre autres
et plus généralement par la volonté
patronale de les rendre invisibles pour
éviter les coûts financiers de leur
prévention quel que soit d'ailleurs pour
le coup le genre il y a par contre un
risque que les employeurs ne peuvent pas
sous-estimer la maternité elle apparaît
à certains employeurs comme une charge
insupportable or le repérage des
nuisances justement potentielles pour la
grossesse représente la première étape
d'une évaluation spécifique anticipée et
intégrée à l'évaluation globale des
risques professionnels
autre problématique dans la
sous-déclaration des maladies
professionnelles cette sous-déclaration
non plus n'est pas malheureusement
spécifique aux travailleuses
malheureusement je dis c'est spécifié
c'est pas spécifique c'est fréquent
quelque soit le genre la peur de perdre
d'emploi à des postes de travail souvent
les moins qualifiés la méconnaissance
des tableaux de maladies
professionnelles quand ils existent par
les médecins de soins et en particulier
des médecins généralistes expliquent en
partie donc cette sous-déclaration
autre situation donc essentielle alors
le congé menstruel pour nous on pense
après on est un débat mais pour nous
parce que pour l'instant c'est pas
forcément une solution en tout cas il
pourrait stigmatiser les femmes et ne
pas prendre en compte justement il ne
prend pas en compte par le pardon les
endométriose car il n'y a pas une
endométriose mais plusieurs aujourd'hui
la difficulté pour les femmes qui
souffrent d'endométriose c'est de
pouvoir se mettre en maladie sans bâtir
entre autres des trois jours de carence
une réflexion donc doit s'engager pour
supprimer les difficultés que rencontre
ces femmes pouvoir se mettre en maladie
sans impact sur leur salaire ou leur
carrière professionnelle donc
suppression je lui ai dit des jours de
carence que ça soit d'un secteur privé
public et création d'indemnité
journalière spécifique une prise en
charge de l'employeur de la des 50%
sécurité sociale
par ailleurs il faudrait pouvoir faire
reconnaître aussi l'endométriose comme
un handicap pour que les femmes qui en
souffrent puissent accéder donc à la
reconnaissance de qualité de
travailleurs handicapé de façon plus
automatique comme c'est le cas pour la
polyarthrite rhumatoïde dont son sujet
très majoritairement les femmes
par ailleurs il faudrait uniformiser les
décisions et les moyens à toutes les
maisons départementales des personnes
handicapées car elles n'ont pas toutes
les mêmes temps de traitement de dossier
ni de procédures voire de décision
donc à ce jour l'endométriose n'est même
pas ouverte à une infection longue durée
ce qui serait un premier pas et qui
n'empêche rien donc la demande d'une
reconnaissance de qualité de
travailleurs handicapés
pour finir ce qui concerne les violences
sexistes et sexuelles la France donc
vous le savez viendractifier la
convention 190 de l'OIT qui est
accompagné d'une recommandation de 106
mais la France donc a annoncé que la
ratification serait fait à droite
constante cette convention cette
convention prévoit par exemple la
promotion de la négociation collective à
tous les niveaux or si aujourd'hui la
négociation est obligatoire sur ces
sujets dans les conventions de branches
ce n'est pas le cas donc dans
l'entreprise l'égalité professionnelle
doit être négociée dans les entreprises
mais pas donc la question des violences
sexistes et sexuelles dans la fonction
publique il y a une obligation de mettre
en place un dispositif de signalement
mais la négociation n'est pas non plus
obligatoire la mise en place de cette
dispositif et aujourd'hui encore peu de
collectivités territoriales et
d'hôpitaux en sont dotés
et le peu de dispositifs dont de
signalements qui sont mis en place sont
en plus pour la plupart inopérant
les références CSE en matière de lutte
contre le harcèlement sexuel à gisant
sexiste sont plus régulièrement désignés
dans les CSE du privé mais très rarement
dans la fonction publique
il est également prévu dans cette
convention qui est une indemnisation des
victimes de violence dans le monde du
travail or cette disposition peut être
mise en place dans la fonction publique
avec l'ordonnance de protection mais
n'est pas appliquée dans le privé
cette convention prévoit d'éviter la
récidive des auteurs et leur insertion
dans le monde du travail mais encore une
fois sur ce sujet rien est prévu
des dispositions particulières sont
également prévues pour protéger les
femmes victimes de violences domestiques
mais rien n'est fait on sait pourtant
que le seul moyen de s'émanciper d'un
conjoint violent pour une femme c'est en
tout cas c'est son travail donc nous
avons proposé
si j'étais une étude d'impact que nous
pourrons vous faire parvenir si ça vous
intéresse par la suite et après pour
finir donc dernier élément vous savez
certainement aussi l'accès aux soins en
France est difficile pour 9,5 millions
de femmes elle constitue la majorité des
personnes précaires donc 53% des
personnes pauvres sont des femmes 57%
des bénéficiaires du revenu de solidaire
de solidarité active
donc souvent les femmes se prive de
soins où ils ont renoncé dans les 12
dernières mois pour 64% d'entre elles
merci
merci beaucoup madame verceletier est-ce
que Monsieur perron avait imaginé
complété le propos ou vous préférez
répondre aux questions
micro peut-être
mais mettez le micro s'il vous plaît
monsieur pardon oui je crois que tout a
été dit et bien dit par ma camarade donc
je vais pas je vais pas rajouter grand
chose
appuyer sur un fait compter sur les
législateur pour faire en sorte que les
moyens de contrôle soit un peu plus
efficace et plus développé que ce soit
des dreads ou des ou des carsats CRAMIF
enfin tout tout
enfin type CARSAT comme l'a dit Céline
et il y a il y a un réel manque de
moyens aujourd'hui la loi existe la loi
existe le du
ERP qui est un moyen de prévention des
risques
j'en aurai ou pas en tout cas
les lois existent par contre les faire
appliquer ce serait ce serait une
avancée et la réintroduction des CHSCT
pourrait aussi aider ce fait et on y
tient à la CGT voilà
et bien merci beaucoup madame monsieur
pour cette présentation je vais
immédiatement passer la parole à madame
Diane de Perroy qui est représente le
Medef
merci beaucoup
bonjour à tous voilà un beau sujet et je
pense que j'ai envie de me référer
à cette année et à cette loi santé au
travail qui a été bâti la nuit dans un
cadre paritaire de cette démocratie
sociale à laquelle nous tenons beaucoup
et puis après cette transposition dans
le cadre parlementaire et il me semble
que au travers du desurp au travers
aussi de l'approche de qualité de vie
des conditions de travail que nous
souhaitons bien sûr promouvoir au
travers du Plan Santé 4 et bien il y a
beaucoup d'éléments sur lesquels
s'appuyait pour faire en sorte de les
faire connaître de les diffuser toujours
plus davantage on ne peut jamais
s'arrêter de diffuser une parole
préventive et informative et bien je
pense que nous avons des socles nombreux
pour répondre au point soulevé je
voudrais souligner notamment
l'insistance qui a été la nôtre celle
des partenaires sociaux mais aussi dans
le cadre de la loi du 2 août 21 qui
faisait suite aussi à cette loi que vous
avez évoqué de 2014 et bien nous avons
insisté sur une offre de services et
d'accompagnement des entreprises parce
que nous pensons avant tout qu'il y a
tout ce travail à faire pour mieux faire
connaître
l'accompagnement dont peuvent bénéficier
les entreprises et bien évidemment les
salariés et nous pensons que tout le
travail fait au sein de la médecine du
travail que celle-ci soit dans le cadre
des spsti je me permets d'insister sur
le P que nous avons introduit avec les
partenaires sociaux dans le cadre de la
nuit puis de la loi le P grandir
prévention et c'est vrai aussi pour les
spsta c'est-à-dire les centres de
travail les centres de santé au travail
autonome lorsqu'ils sont au sein des
grandes entreprises et nous pensons que
la médecine du travail notamment au
travers de toutes les équipes qui sont
présentes qu'elles soient médicales ou
paramédicales ou d'accompagnement et
bien sont très importants pour
accompagner les salariés notamment les
femmes dans la sensibilisation dans la
mise en avant de ce qui peut être des
mesures qui leur permettent là aussi de
prendre conscience de ce capital de la
santé alors vous avez cité dans votre
propos introductif la sous-estimation
des risques professionnels auxquels les
femmes sont exposées vous me permettrez
de faire remarquer qu'il ne nous sommes
pas opportuns Medef de parler de
sous-estimation des risques
professionnels des femmes
cela veut pas dire qu'il ne faut pas
absolument continuer à pousser les
efforts de prévention tout
particulièrement dans les secteurs à
forte prédominance d'emploi féminins je
voudrais souligner tout le travail qui
est fait entreprise mais branche à
branche aussi dans certains secteurs où
les femmes sont très présentes je pense
au secteur de la propreté la Fédération
des Entreprises de la propreté qui a
renouvelé une convention nationale
d'objectif avec la CNAM en 2021 et avec
des incitations et un investissement
dans les équipements de travail les plus
adaptés dans la formation à
l'utilisation de ces équipements dans
l'évaluation de la prévention aussi des
risques chimiques auxquels lorsqu'on est
par exemple dans le nettoyage des locaux
ou le personnel féminin est très
important et bien qu'il puisse y avoir
de la formation de la sensibilisation et
là aussi des matériels qui permettent
d'être accompagnés dans ce type de
secteur de la même façon dans le
commerce je voudrais donner aussi ces
exemples où il y a souvent une présence
féminine très importante et des socles
qui ont été vus dans le cadre de travaux
en comité technique distribution à sa
regroupe service commerce et industrie
de l'alimentation et bien tout
l'accompagnement la sensibilisation
autour de la mise en rayon la
manutention manuelle des charges et des
mesures de prévention évidemment qui dit
mesure de prévention dit nécessité
d'informations pour que jusqu'au plus
proche du terrain ces mesures soient
connues appliquées relayés de la même
façon le secteur du grand âge est aussi
un secteur où il y a une prédominance de
personnel féminin le grand âge je mets
les EHPAD je mets les services les
résidences Sen les agences d'aide et de
soins à domicile là aussi il y a un
travail fait sur les TMS pro et donc
parce que évidemment on peut imaginer le
travail avec des postures contraignantes
qui peut être effectuée et donc tous les
équipements qui peuvent être mis en
place d'accompagnement des salariés
autour des lèvres personnes des lits
médicalisés etc nous pourrions aller
plus loin mais je ne veux pas prendre
trop de temps là-dessus ces exemples je
voulais vous les citer parce que je
crois qu'ils sont importants pour
montrer qu'il y a des démarches
volontaristes en termes de prévention ça
n'est jamais assez il faut toujours
poursuivre et d'ailleurs dans la
négociation en cours que je ne veux pas
préempter entre les partenaires sociaux
donc sur la négociation ATMP dont une
séance est prévue le 15 mai à nouveau à
l'issue de travaux importants et bien
c'est autour de toute cette dynamique
que l'on doit pouvoir poursuivre et
mieux diffuser l'information sur ces
sujets là de la même façon je voulais
aussi mentionné que on dit que il y a
une hausse d'accident du travail chez
les femmes et en fait il faut faire le
lien avec le fait qu'il y a de plus en
plus de femmes en activité et puis
certains secteurs après dominance
féminine je vous en ai parlé peuvent
avoir des niveaux de sinistralité plus
élevés et donc s'engage particulièrement
à travailler à la prévention et à
l'équipement
d'outils permettant d'aider à faire en
sorte qu'il n'y ait pas ce type de
danger et d'accidents mais aussi de
maladies et de problèmes alors vous avez
mentionné aussi les sujets de santé
sexuelle reproductive je voudrais avant
tout souligner que pour le chef
d'entreprise il y a toujours une crainte
de faire un traitement différencié entre
les hommes et les femmes et ce
traitement s'il était avéré pourrait
être considéré comme discriminant donc
il faut toujours que nous ayons en tête
le fait de ne pas être dans ces logiques
là le chef d'entreprise s'appuie bien
sûr sur le durp avec toute cette analyse
et la mise en avant que là aussi les
partenaires sociaux et la loi d'août 21
a permis pour sensibiliser et faire en
sorte que le du RP soit partout présent
et en même temps accompagnés pour le
faire parce qu'on s'est rendu compte
lors de nos analyses et de notre
audition que ça n'était pas toujours le
cas et que parfois les chefs
d'entreprise notamment dans les petites
entreprises pouvaient être perdus je
voudrais souligner aussi un point qui
est très important et après je vais
revenir au cas particulier que vous avez
évoqué le pst4 qui a mis en exergue
ergonomie des équipements au travail et
les équipements de protection
individuels et c'est vrai qu'ils sont
souvent dans une logique définie à
partir de modèles qui représentent on va
dire un homme moyen n'y voyait pas un
jugement de ma part bien divinement
mettez des guillemets autour de cette
expression mais en termes de taille
notamment et de prise en compte des
caractéristiques féminines physiques
féminines et il s'agit d'être vigilant
de façon à aller plus loin dans ces
équipements pour qu'ils soient mieux
adaptés aux caractéristiques des gens
qui les portent alors sur l'aspect que
vous avez mentionné tout à l'heure
je voudrais revenir d'abord sur la santé
au travail et toutes les mesures qui
datent d'ailleurs du 19e siècle sur la
santé la sécurité avec des premières
lois sociales qui se sont construites
pour protéger la mer et la future mère
la femme enceinte et il est important en
effet de porter attention à ces sujets
là et nous disposons d'un cadre vraiment
complet intéressant et de protection de
la femme salariée enceinte je ne vais
pas le détailler mais il y a énormément
de mesures peut-être que docteur vous y
reviendrait je ne sais pas mais c'est un
point très important avec même
l'obligation pour l'employeur de
reclasser la personne enceinte
lorsqu'elle est exposée à certains
risques déterminés par décret des agents
toxiques du plomb en ce qui concerne les
différentes actions menées par les
partenaires sociaux en faveur de la
santé des femmes il y a ce chemin
toujours à poursuivre et nous sommes
très intéressés toujours très vigilants
à analyser les travaux menés par l'INRS
qui sont un éclairage et c'est un outil
paritaire de la branche ATMP c'est un
éclairage et il faut poursuivre ces
travaux là il faut le faire que ces
organismes puissent mener ces travaux et
il y a un dossier très intéressant je ne
peux que vous y renvoyez de l'INRS
autour de la prévention du harcèlement
sexuel et des agissements consiste au
travail et donc il faut que la branche
ATMP et les moyens d'accompagner les
entreprises et les secteurs qui sont en
demande de la même façon nous souhaitons
que les décrets
issus de la loi santé au travail du 4
août 2021 notamment sur les IPA les
infirmiers et infirmières en pratique
avancées et les médecins praticiens
correspondants que c'est des crêpes
puissent voir le jour je le sais qu'ils
sont en cours d'élaboration et de
travail mais ils sont très importants
parce que c'est aussi par ce personnel
présent sur le terrain que les salariés
seront accompagnés et vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui la démographie médicale
fait que il y a souvent des manques de
personnels et donc nous sommes vigilants
et particulièrement en attente de la
publication de ces décrets qui me paraît
rejoindre aussi parce que c'est aussi
ces personnels là que les femmes peuvent
aller voir peuvent aller consulter pour
justement avec le secret médical qui les
caract et bien évoquer des pathologies
dont elle pourrait souffrir quel que
soit ces pathologies et bien évidemment
tout particulièrement les pathologies
que vous avez évoqué autour de
l'endométriose et autres pathologies
autour de celle-là mais en même temps il
nous paraît important que ce sujet de la
menstruation ne soit pas une pathologie
en soi qui sommes-nous pour le décider
il s'agit bien d'une relation avec le
corps médical et en même temps il s'agit
d'être vigilant et de pouvoir
accompagner les salariés pour que les
salariés connaissent leurs droits
connaissent les endroits où elles
peuvent parler dialoguer avec le corps
médical et là encore je pense que il
faut être vigilant au risque de
stigmatisation d'une hausse des
stéréotypes au détriment des femmes je
pense que il pourrait si nous allions
dans cette mention d'un congé menstruel
renforcer des stéréotypes qui seraient
tout à fait
erronées selon les cas les femmes
seraient plus vulnérables et ne
pourraient pas
occuper des postes identiques aux
salariés masculins à travailler égal je
pense que il ne s'agit pas de verser
dans cette dimension là même si le Medef
est particulièrement attentif à la
diffusion de parole préventives à
l'accès à la médecine du travail et au
fait de pouvoir avoir des communications
de sensibilisation cela rejoint les
violences sexistes et sexuelles au
travail nous avons un socre légal qui
permet au chef d'entreprise de pouvoir
prendre toutes les mesures pour
sanctionner ces agissements en quête
sanctions disciplinaire il s'agit
vraiment de les faire connaître et de
pouvoir les mettre en avant et de les
relayer c'est aussi le sens de cette
accompagnement dont les chefs
d'entreprise peuvent bénéficier voilà je
m'arrêterai là à ce stade mais je
voudrais en conclusion dire que il y a
des entreprises il y a des organisations
il y a des branches et de la même façon
la TP et la caisse ATMP est importante
là-dessus il faut pouvoir accompagner il
faut pouvoir développer toujours plus la
prévention et pour cela il faut avoir
encore davantage de moyens merci
beaucoup de votre attention
merci à vous madame donc notre dernière
intervenant et Monsieur Pierre Tillot
qui est donc représentant pour la CGPME
à vous cher Monsieur
avant de commencer premièrement c'est
que au regard de l'action résolument
novatrice que porte la majorité des
partenaires sociaux depuis plus de 2 ans
j'éprouve je dois le confesser une
certaine gêne sur la thématique de cette
table ronde
un patron de PME ne procède qu'à
l'embauchage d'un salarié
et qu'il soit homme ou femme
sa responsabilité en matière de santé au
travail et de prévention des risques
professionnels restent égal
c'est tout le sens de l'anis signé en
décembre 2020
un parfaitement repris dans la loi du 2
août 2021
sans ce que de s'affranchir de tout
communautarisme sanitaire
pour établir durablement et pour tous
le concept de prévention primaire
de s'assurer d'un soutien de proximité
attentionné et performant du spsti dont
vous connaissez maintenant la
signification de cet acronyme nous
l'avons inventé tous ensemble et pour
pour établir durablement
pour établir durablement et pour tous le
concept de prévention primaire et de
s'assurer donc du soutien de proximité
attentionné et performant des
entreprises adhérentes DSP STI les PME
tout particulièrement
de veiller enfin au développement adapté
de la prévention de la désinsertion
professionnelle c'est également le sens
de la ni ATMP qui on vous l'a dit est en
cours d'achèvement nous le souhaitons
prochain d'obtenir la réappropriation
par les partenaires sociaux d'une
branche ATMP rendu plus autonome
de se doter d'un véritable problème
d'action de prévention primaire
de s'engager résolument dans la
surveillance et la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle dans le cadre du fipu
introduit avec la nouvelle réforme des
retraites
ceci étant
de nombreux postes de travail se sont
nouvellement ouverts aux femmes
à l'évidence
cette évolution relève de la prévention
des risques professionnels de la
prévention primaire
qui prie les véligies l'innocuité du
poste à l'adaptation de son opérateur
qu'il soit homme qu'il soit femme
cette attitude n'est pas nouvelle la
réglementation du port des charges
lourdes est à sa manière jeanrée depuis
le début du 20e siècle
et à ce titre il est remarquable de
constater que les 250 pages comportant
plusieurs dizaines de tableaux du
rapport de gestion 2021 de la Direction
des Risques Professionnels de la CNAM un
seul un seul seulement
consacré à la sinistralité des
bicyclettes et des trottinettes et j'en
Rey
vous avez reçu
récemment la
DRP de la CNAM dans le cadre de vos
travaux et vous avez pu vous rendre
compte combien
cette approche jeanrée de la
connaissance de la sinistralité au
travail et difficile est incertaine bien
que la loi de 2014 aurait pu laisser à
penser qu'elle soit effective plus
rapidement il n'en est rien et je crois
que ces éléments sont importants
l'approche Jean Rey
de la sinistralité est
utile pour la connaissance elle nous
paraît pas souhaitable pour les actions
de prévention
l'INRS dont on a déjà évoqué l'existence
répugne depuis toujours à produire au
nom de l'universalité de la prévention
des études genrées
ce sont des réalités
enfin à propos des affections propres
aux femmes que vous avez bien voulu
évoquer
vous diront que l'endométriose est une
maladie
les règles douloureuses forment un
syndrome physiopathologique
l'une comme l'autre n'est pas sans
conséquence sur le travail mais aucune
des deux ne sont la conséquence du
travail
dans ces conditions ces deux situations
morbides relèvent plus de la médecine de
soins du médecin traitant et de l'arrêt
de travail que de la convention
collective et d'un éventuel congé
spécifique
peut-être que cette proposition
allégerait les comptes de la Sécurité
sociale
mais elle serait à coup sûr une charge
financière considérable imposée aux
seules entreprises et aux PME tout
particulièrement
pour autant
nous avons quelques données et c'est
vrai que je suis nous sommes les PME
plus inquiets par les TMS au regard du
travail des femmes que par les
événements morbides que vous avez
signalés les affections périarticulaires
provoquées par certains gestes et
postures de travail tableau 57
fait que il y a 37
maladies déclarées en 2021
et 60% d'entre elles l'ont été par des
femmes cela me paraît un problème majeur
qu'il convient à priori de prendre à bas
le corps c'est le sens de la prévention
primaire
en tous les cas cette pour autant
faut-il accepter que tous les actifs
hommes et femmes continuent à voir leur
santé saucissonnée entre celle qui
relève de la santé du citoyen santé
publique celle du patient médecin
traitant celle du travailleur santé au
travail la CPME de le pense pas
il a dit signé par les partenaires
sociaux en décembre 2020 non plus
la proposition largement portée par la
CPME de mettre en place la fonction
nouvelle de médecin praticien
correspondant les MPC visite à répondre
à la nécessité d'une approche globale de
la santé tout en préservant la
spécificité de chacun de ces
professionnels de santé le MPC dans
notre volonté
aurait pu aurait dû être le médecin
traitant qui en établissant un pont
sanitaire entre la santé du travailleur
et celle du patient et avec le médecin
conseil de la sécurité sociale
aurait pu initier cette approche globale
de la santé de la femme de l'homme au
travail une approche indispensable à
toute politique de prévention primaire
les parlementaires n'ont pas voulu
partager cette ambition la CME le
regrette d'autant plus que la promotion
de la prévention de la désinsertion
professionnelle pousse à cette
collaboration et que le fipu ne sera
sans affranchir merci
et bien écoutez merci à vous à vous tous
pour ces présentations qui auront permis
de nous plonger directement avec des
présentations variées très différentes
et qui vont forcément amener des
réactions et des questionnements de nos
rapporteurs et je vais tout de suite
passer la parole dans l'ordre Laurence
Rossignol je vous laisserai répondre
ensuite Laurence Cohen et peut-être
Annick jacquemer apporteur qui nous a
rejoint également
évidemment puisque elle est avec nous si
elle le souhaite elle pourra poser des
questions madame la rapporte merci nous
vous remercions effectivement de vos
communications
comment vous dire
Monsieur le Représentant de ces PME vous
avez dit d'être gêné par la thématique
de la Table Ronde
alors moi je suis un peu gêné pour vous
interroger parce que le fait le but de
ces auditions n'est pas d'engager
une discussion et d'essayer de vous
convaincre d'un certain nombre de choses
je ne vais pas me substituer aux
partenaire sociaux et en particulier au
syndicat de ton c'est la tâche et vous
avez des réunions partenaires sociaux
pour faire ça pour autant
vous avez vous-même reconnu et je vous
en céderai que les vous avez dit que la
dimension genre a été utile pour la
compréhension la connaissance mais qui
n'était pas utile pour je reprends vos
mots pour les
actions de prévention mais en fait
comment vous dire à quoi servirait des
statistiques j'enrées si elles ne nous
disent pas comment agir par la suite ça
marche pour tout pas spécialement pour
la santé au travail ça marche pour
l'ensemble des activités humaines y
compris pour les nôtres
vous dire c'est quand on a compté quand
on s'est mis à compter les femmes dans
le monde politique on a décidé qu'il
fallait passer à une loi sur la parité
avant de les compter on trouvait que
c'est normal qu'il n'est que des hommes
donc voilà à quoi ça sert donc voilà je
voulais vous faire cette remarque là
pour qu'il y ait pas de d'ambiguïté
entre nous sur ce sur quoi nous
travaillons
donc j'ai pas énormément de questions à
vous poser en fait j'ai compris quel
était votre approche j'ai
malgré tout une frustration j'aurais
aimé que côté Medef et côté PME on nous
parle aussi de la santé des femmes chefs
d'entreprise commerçante parce que ce
sont aussi des femmes et puis en fait je
voulais vous dire une chose aussi c'est
que pourquoi ne pas entrer des femmes au
travail parce que nous savons que la
grossesse
il fait d'avoir des enfants sont des
facteurs d'inégalité professionnelle
clairement identifiées et pour des
raisons aussi de santé donc comment on
fait pour que les données de santé
spécifiques aux femmes ne se traduisent
pas en stagnation de carrière régression
et inégalités professionnelle également
et en matière comme nous nous
intéressons aux salariés mais aussi au
chef d'entreprise monsieur commerçante
mais aussi aux femmes chefs de petits et
moyennes entreprises et j'ai du mal à
croire qu'il n'y ait pas de pour elle de
spécificité
en termes sanitaire dans le lien entre
le fait qu'elles sont des femmes et
quelle est leur activité je pense que
j'attends pas des syndicats de salariés
qui nous instruent là-dessus mais vous
vous pourriez peut-être le faire et les
femmes chez l'entreprise vous intéresse
aussi en fait dernière question ça
concerne le congé menstruel proposit
l'endroit plus en propositions de doigts
sont déposées Vous avez
vous avez tous j'imagine compris que ces
propositions de loi vise à supprimer le
délai de carence donc c'est une question
qui relève essentiellement du roi de la
sécurité sociale mais que pour les
entreprises ça implique aussi que dès
lors que une femme est titulaire ça
impliquerait pardon tous ces
conditionnés dès lors qu'une femme est
titulaire d'un arrêt de maladie sur une
longue période qui lui ouvre
effectivement un droit à congé sans jour
de carence du point de vue de la
sécurité sociale ça parle des
entreprises qu'on va d'accord de
mensualisation pour lesquelles les
interventions de prévoiraient pas ça ça
veut dire que en revanche dans les
entreprises il faut que ces femmes
soient protégées dans leur activité
professionnelle c'est-à-dire que là
encore ce ne soit pas pour elle un
facteur de discrimination ou de
sanctions au travail j'ai pas compris
Michel Medef chez vous madame chez vous
monsieur est-ce que vous êtes favorable
ou hostile assez proposé sur le Do IGT
merci Madame la rapporteur donc comme
les questions de de Laurence Rossignol
était plutôt adressée au MEDEF et à la
CGPME je vous laisse je vous laisse je
vous laisse répondre madame monsieur
merci beaucoup pour pour ces points
alors c'est vrai que je n'ai pas fait un
cas particulier des chefs d'entreprise
femme ou homme d'ailleurs parce que dans
la nuit que nous avons partagé dans ce
cadre paritaire et dans la loi en 21
nous avons justement embarqué les chefs
d'entreprise et les professions
indépendantes sur la base du volontariat
ça n'existait pas jusqu'à l'or et
justement nous avons dans le cadre de
nos échanges était sensibilisés au fait
que il ne s'agissait pas de les laisser
de côté et au contraire il fallait les
embarquer et leur donner ce droit
d'accès au spsti puisqu'en l'occurrence
là il s'agit pas de des spsta mais bien
des centres de santé donc votre point
est tout à fait pertinent et ils ont
bien été embarqués dans la nuit 21 qui a
été traduit après si je reviens sur le
deuxième point et puis docteur je vous
passerai la parole après si ça vous
convient sur le deuxième point il nous
semble que il est très important de
mettre le poids sur la prévention sur la
communication sur l'accès notamment à la
médecine du travail ça nous paraît très
important de ne pas transformer certains
sujets comme
les sujets de menstruation comme des
sujets relevant d'une pathologie
systématique et d'un facteur qui
handicaperait l'ensemble des salariés
tous les mois en tout cas les salariés
qui sont
assujettis à ces menstruations tous les
mois ça ne nous paraît absolument pas le
chemin qu'il faut poursuivre donc en
expliquant cela je vous dis deux choses
je dis d'abord
il y a la médecine du travail l'accès le
secret médical il y a un dialogue il y a
la capacité d'avoir des congés malades
si dans le cas de ce dialogue médical
dans le cadre de ce secret du dialogue
médical cela devait résulter par un
arrêt de travail mais je veux pas me
substituer aux gens dont c'est le métier
les médecins et en même temps il est
important d'être très vigilant au risque
de stigmatisation d'une hausse des
stéréotypes au détriment des femmes et
ça je crois que c'est un point qui est
important et donc ça veut dire que en
revanche le fait que il puisse y avoir
des communications qu'il puisse y avoir
une connaissance plus approfondie de
cette maladie qu'elle puisse donner lieu
le cas échéant à des arrêts mais là je
parle de maladie
excusez-moi merci beaucoup constaté par
le corps médical mais en revanche la
menstruation je pense que si elle est
jugée douloureuse c'est dans le cas de
ce dialogue avec cet acte médical mais
que en revanche il ne s'agit pas d'être
dans ce dans cette ce risque de
stigmatisation en instaurant ce type de
congé en revanche prévenir communiquer
sensibiliser sur ces différents sujets
c'est très important et on a jamais
arrêté de faire ce chemin de prévention
et je rejoindrai le propos du docteur on
voit que dans les exemples que je vous
ai cité dans ces secteurs à exposition
forte féminine je fais allusion au
secteur que je vous ai cité tout à
l'heure du commerce du secteur de la
propreté du secteur du grand âge et Jean
globe plusieurs sujets là dessous et
bien il nous semble que toutes les
dimensions autour des TMS il y a aussi
du risque chimique à certains endroits
et bien sont des dimensions qui doivent
être particulièrement travaillées parce
que elles vont rejoindre un personnel
féminin qui est particulièrement
concentré dans ces secteurs là merci de
votre attention docteur je vous laisse
la parole
je partage votre réaction en
communautarisme sanitaire puisque
justement tout mon propos était de dire
que l'application
sans genre de la prévention primaire
éviter ce risque car c'est un risque
c'est pas une stigmatisation
la deuxième chose c'est que vous avez
raison c'est mon propos aurait été
incohérence si j'avais mis en exergue
les femmes patrons de PME
elles appartiennent comme le reste et
elle bénéficie comme le reste d'une
prévention primaire donc depuis l'année
de décembre 2020 les chefs d'entreprise
ont accès volontaire à au bénéfice au
soutien des spsti comme d'ailleurs les
travailleurs indépendants et
nous sommes assez fiers
la PO à la CPME d'avoir pu obtenir cela
et d'avoir constaté qu'il a fallu
attendre autant de temps pour ouvrir
l'accès à la médecine du travail à la
santé au travail à cette catégorie de
professionnels
soyons clairs de la CPME n'est pas
favorable à l'instauration d'un congé
menstruel
pour des raisons que je vous ai
développées ça ne nous paraît relever de
la médecine de soins du médecin traitant
de l'arrêt maladie et non pas je le
répète de la convention collective alors
j'ai signalé que la sécurité sociale
pouvait peut-être y gagner quelques
argent
vous nous avez précisé que c'était en
fait les les salariés qui voulaient en
gagner ne pas en perdre avec le délai de
carence c'est ça que j'ai cru comprendre
mais nous ne
nous semble pas justifier de faire
porter cette charge aux entreprises sur
un syndrome physiopathologique qui n'est
pas systématique et sur une maladie qui
je vous le rappelle au mieux des
statistiques touchent 10% des femmes
si vous me permettez j'aurais peut-être
ajouter un point qui me paraît aussi
devoir être réfléchie il me semble qu'on
devrait aussi s'interroger sur
l'articulation
d'un tel congé tel qu'il est
évoqué avec un des principes forts aussi
que sont la liberté des personnes et le
respect de la vie privée
auxquels sont attachées les salariés
eux-mêmes
c'est un point très important
qui est souvent évoqué au sein de
l'entreprise pas spécifiquement bien sûr
sur ce sujet là mais au sein de la vie
des entreprises
cet accès cette confidentialité est un
point important pour pouvoir échanger
donc il faut à la fois faire connaître
et encore mieux
les possibilités qui existent notamment
au travers de la médecine du travail et
ça englobe comme vous le rappeliez les
chefs d'entreprise il faut qu'on fasse
mieux connaître qu'ils ont ce droit cet
accès maintenant qui est vraiment
quelque chose de de très bien et de mais
comme vous faisiez allusion à la
prévention de la désinsertion
professionnelle par exemple nous avons
dans le cadre paritaire instaurer une
possibilité de cette visite de
prévention des insertions voilà j'élargi
le propos mais je crois que c'est un peu
la même logique merci de votre attention
merci à vous madame monsieur donc je
vais passer la parole à Madame la
rapporteur Laurence Cohen qui je ne
doute pas à des questions et des
interrogations à vous poser ensuite ce
sera la rapporteur à nickel mais
merci madame la Présidente merci
benidormes et messieurs pour la
franchise de vos propos donc je vais je
vais être tout aussi franche que vous et
en vous entendant notamment
au niveau du Medef et de la CPME je
pense qu'on a bien fait de d'utiliser et
de prendre en compte cette thématique de
la santé des femmes au travail et qui a
vraiment encore beaucoup de choses à
faire au niveau des entreprises pour
faire progresser
à cette thématique alors pourquoi je dis
ça parce que j'ai l'impression que
en vous entendant notamment
on vit pas dans le même monde on vit pas
dans le même monde et on rencontre pas
les mêmes salariés
il n'y a pas de sous-estimation de la
prise en compte de la santé des femmes
madame de Perroy toutes les statistiques
prouvent le contraire alors vous avez
raison il y a effectivement apprendre en
compte une hausse du nombre des femmes
au travail sans doute mais
néanmoins il y a aussi à prendre en
compte et c'est ce que d'ailleurs ma
collègue Laurence Rossignol a dit les
métiers qui sont après dominance
féminine et pour lesquels les femmes
vivent des conditions particulièrement
difficiles et quand je dis nous ne
vivons pas dans le même monde c'est que
vous parlez d'une médecine du travail
qui n'existe pas
alors c'est pas de votre responsabilité
c'est pas vous effectivement qui fait en
sorte que la médecine du travail soit
dans cet état là mais c'est vous avez
quand même à prendre en compte cette
réalité
de terrain et quand vous parlez
prévention je peux partager le fait que
effectivement il y a une nécessité de
préhension
mais elle est extrêmement faible contenu
de la médecine du travail qui est qui
est sinistrée et je pense et là j'ai un
désaccord vraiment profond c'est que
parler des problèmes spécifiques qui
sont vécus au travail par les femmes ça
n'est pas les stigmatisés pour moi
s'abriter derrière cette cette excuse je
vais dire ça permet de ne pas agir
et donc
on l'a vu et on le voit dans tous les
combats que nous pouvons mener à la
délégation droit des femmes
il y a besoin effectivement d'avoir un
regard
sur
les femmes dans la société et les femmes
dans la société c'est en politique c'est
c'est au travail c'est dans la vie
domestique donc ça c'est c'est pas être
vraiment une question c'est plutôt une
remarque
et
quand on dit qu'il faut quand je
souligne qu'il faut avoir ce regard
spécifique je peux vous donner je peux
vous donner des exemples
vous parlez des troubles musculo
squelettiques et vous avez parlé
notamment
des
appareils qui permettent la levée des
poids pour les malades etc c'est
effectivement vous avez raison
extrêmement important mais ça n'est pas
dans tous les lieux
de travail qu'il existe de telles
facilitateurs
on voit que les femmes qui sont auprès
des personnes
âgées on va dire
vivent des conditions de travail telles
que c'est dans ce secteurs qu'il y a un
taux d'accident du travail qui est plus
élevé que BTP par exemple donc qu'est-ce
que vous faites par rapport à ça
quand monsieur d'ailleurs c'est pareil
et monsieur je vais parvenir sur
communautarisme sanitaire ça m'a
extrêmement choqué et je partage qu'a
dit Laurence Rossignol et vous
explications n'ont pas convaincu mais
quand vous parlez par exemple de ne pas
avoir l'un et l'autre n'est pas avoir
spécialement
un regard genré par rapport aux actions
c'est
je ne comprends pas je ne comprends pas
ce raisonnement pourquoi je le comprends
pas je vais prendre un exemple très
simple je vais prendre l'exemple des
facteurs
au début c'était des hommes
essentiellement qui avait les musettes
qui allaient apporter le courrier mais
les musées pour les hommes même si les
stéréotypes font que les hommes sont
très virils costauds qui peuvent prendre
des charges très lourdes ils cherchent
très lourdes ont des conséquences aussi
sur leur squelette sur leur musculation
sur etc et mais ils ronchait pas il
portait une musette et quand il y a eu
des femmes factrices elles se sont
battues elles ont obtenu effectivement
un allégement des musettes et ça a
profité et aux femmes et aux hommes et
là on a constaté qu'effectivement
c'était pas bien de porter des charges
lourdes donc ce que je veux dire par là
par cet exemple mais il y en aurait
plein d'autres c'est que quand on
s'intéresse à ce qui se passe réellement
dans l'entreprise et notamment au niveau
des femmes et bien ça des conséquences
d'améliorations du travail pour tout le
monde et donc ça aussi des améliorations
de productivité par rapport au chef
d'entreprise troisième remarque
on n'a pas parlé enfin vous avez très
peu parlé des violences sexuelles et
sexistes moi j'aimerais bien que vous en
parliez au niveau du du Medef et CPME
c'est que ces gpma c'est que
les on a vu et on a constaté dans tout
le travail que nous avons fait que les
femmes qui sont victimes la majorité des
femmes qui sont victimes de violence
sexuelles et sexistes
en fait au bout du bout quitte leur
travail
c'est elle qui sont discriminés c'est
pas c'est pas les bourreaux
en général ils ont une petite table sur
les doigts et puis ils peuvent garder
leur poste c'est pas eux qui sont
déplacés
et donc les conséquences sont
extrêmement grasse qu'est-ce que vous
faites par rapport à ça dernière
question nous n'avons pas parlé et
pourtant on vient vivre une crise
extrêmement grave sanitaire sur le covid
nous n'avons pas parlé du télétravail
et je pense qu'il y a un regard
particulier des conséquences
particulières par rapport à la santé des
femmes là encore il y a des statistiques
importantes et d'une manière générale
c'est vrai pour les femmes et c'est vrai
pour les hommes le droit à des
connexions etc il y a plein de choses
qui sont à faire progresser pour la
santé de tout et de tous mais
particulièrement pour les femmes voilà
je vous remercie merci Madame la
rapporteur je vais vous laisser
intervenir peut-être que si la CGT aussi
imagine apporter des réponses
complémentaires aux interventions de nos
collègues rapporteurs n'hésitez pas à
demander la parole également madame
viennent de Perroy pour le meilleur
merci beaucoup pour vos remarques mais
je crois que nous ne ne différencons pas
tant que ça vous avez évoqué dans votre
premier point parler ce n'est pas un
stigmatiser mais je n'ai absolument pas
dit le contraire je suis complètement en
lien avec vous j'ai dit informer
accompagner prévenir sensibiliser et
donc
en fonction de prévention si c'est juste
sur une feuille de papier ça n'existe
pas les entreprises doivent être
accompagnées il doit y avoir des
communications et des programmes de
sensibilisation et on est complètement
en lien là-dessus j'ai évoqué un risque
de stigmatisation mais en effet tous les
programmes de sensibilisation qui sont
faits au travers de la médecine du
travail dans les entreprises ou au
travers de l'engagement des branches
elles-mêmes en lien avec les caisses
ATMP ou séparément ou au travers de
l'engagement propre de chacune des
entreprises font que ça fait oeuvre
utile indispensable au sein des
entreprises et je crois avoir exprimé
des exemples de secteurs que vous avez
cités également et je vous en remercie
parce que en effet ce sont des secteurs
où vous avez notamment là on est plus
sur le sujet des TMS du port de charge
lourdes ou
d'avoir à déplacer des personnes qui
sont avec des poids importants et qu'il
faut accompagner et au sein des branches
et du secteur privé la sensibilisation
est forte et je vais vous dire que elle
est aussi forte pourquoi parce que il
n'aura échappé à personne que ces
secteurs économiques sont en recherche
aussi de salariés et qu'ils cherchent à
travailler sur la qualité de vie au
travail sur l'équilibre vie
professionnelle vie privée et ces sujets
là ils sont absolument indispensables à
développer si l'on souhaite que ces
secteurs puissent développer l'emploi au
service de la population et d'une partie
spécifique de la population les sujets
autour de l'emploi dans les dans les
EHPAD de l'emploi dans tout ce qui est
le Service à la Personne le nettoyage
que j'ai cité tout à l'heure rejoignent
tout à effet les points que vous avez
partagées et je pourrais même insister
sur un sujet dans les EHPAD il y a des
points d'un programme spécifique qui
s'appelle TMS pro qui est fait en lien
avec les actions de prévention de la
branche ATMP sur les troubles
musculo-squelettiques des subventions
prévention au TPE pour les
établissements de moins de 50 salariés
qui permettent là aussi le financement
d'équipements et de formation en fait
mon point c'est juste de dire que ce qui
est important c'est la réalisation de
l'action et la réalisation de l'action
c'est l'action de prévention de
sensibilisation et c'est l'action sur le
terrain de formation et de dotation
évidemment d'équipement qui sont
nécessaires de la même façon sur les
violences sexuelles et sexistes il y a
eu
des informations majeures qui sont
jamais assez suffisantes mais qui
doivent se poursuivre pour faire
connaître qu'il y a un cadre à ces
sujets un cadre de prévention et qu'il y
a un cadre qui permet de les évoquer de
pouvoir en parler avec tout le
dispositif nécessaire sur ces sujets au
combien douloureux et je voudrais citer
un exemple avec la FHP la fédération de
l'hospitalisation privée évidemment je
m'exprime sur le privé il y a eu par
exemple un réseau d'écoutant formé au
recueil de la parole et mise en place de
procédures de signalement dédiées si on
ne met pas ces cadres là et bien il n'y
aura pas d'expression et donc il faut
que ces cadres soient mis en place mais
que ces cadres soient aussi connus en
novembre 2022 il y a eu également une
campagne de communication dédiée à la
lutte contre les violences rester
sexuelle au travail promouvoir toutes
les actions de protection collective
contre ces violences sensibilisation
accompagnement lignes d'écoute
signalement dédié voilà le groupe Elsa
que je pourrais citer qui me paraît
aussi très important qui a accompagné
les étudiants les étudiants en santé on
sait combien ils peuvent aussi être dans
ce cadre de subir des situations de
violence notamment sexistes et sexuelles
voilà je pourrais en citer d'autres mais
en fait pourquoi je les cite c'est juste
pour dire que en fait ce qui est
important c'est que il y ait des actions
sur le terrain et qu'on fasse preuve de
grands pragmatisme et puis je dirais
pour le télétravail pour avoir été des
RH dans un passé proche en fait lorsque
nous avons réfléchi
au médecin praticien correspondant nous
nous sommes dit à un moment dans les
échanges mais finalement il y a le
travail au travail sur le lieu de
travail clairement identifié et puis il
y a le travail qui peut-être à domicile
et finalement en fonction des équilibres
sur ces temps de travail en fonction des
localisations de ceci finalement est-ce
qu'on ne devrait pas avoir un regard qui
est aussi proche finalement du domicile
et cette notion de médecin praticien
correspondant a été beaucoup partagée
aussi autour de cela que ça ne soit pas
juste la médecine au travail ou par le
travail mais finalement le travail étant
tout lieu notamment en proximité ou chez
soi et donc finalement il y a des
barrières qui tombent et donc on doit
élargir le cadre voilà les réflexions
dont je peux faire part qui ont eu lieu
à ce moment là
ouais c'est possible
non non juste j'ai entendu j'ai entendu
des certaines choses sans les remettre
en couple je vais quand même affirmer la
CGT a pu a pu mettre en avant ces
dernières années il y a j'entends parler
de la loi du 2 août 2021 donc évidemment
dont qui débouchait de l'année de du 9
décembre de l'année précédente il
n'était pas unanime d'une part la CGT la
pas signé alors pour des raisons
diverses dont dont
le MPC nous on regrette cette ce fait
aujourd'hui on préférerait que les
pouvoirs publics mettent en développe
cette cette
médecine du travail est fait face en
sorte que les écoles cette filière soit
développée ça c'est évident les MPC la
médecine générale parce que ce serait
des médecins généralistes finalement qui
s'occuperaient de médecine du travail
sont aussi sinistrés que je crois en
tout cas peut-être que le docteur
Thillot dira le contraire aussi sinistré
que la médecine du travail donc c'est
pas là qu'il faut aller chercher nous en
sommes convaincus et en plus ils
connaissent ils sont trop éloignés des
situations de travail que vivent les
femmes en particulier ces sujets de du
jour il y a aussi les PST j'ai entendu
parler des spsti nous nous notre
revendication forte et qu'on continue à
avoir c'est qu'ils sont intégrés à la
sécurité sociale
on considère qu'il y a des
dysfonctionnements qui sont qui sont
trop portés donc une meilleure
coordination et que les services de
santé au travail soit intégrés à la
sécurité sociale et que ce soit la
sécurité c'est le rôle de la sécurité
sociale
parler aussi des négociations des
négociations qui sont en cours
effectivement il y a des négociations en
cours à la branche ATMP
là aussi on porte des choses fortes dont
les moyens on en parlait tout à l'heure
dans notre dans notre déclaration
initiale c'est les moyens pour les
pour les carsats pour les CRAMIF et pour
pour d'autres structures de ce genre qui
de réels moyens pour que pour que pour
que les contrôles soient effectués et
puis pour que le travail de prévention
soit réellement effectué dans les
entreprises et pour que la j'ai entendu
parler aussi de sinistralité aujourd'hui
nous considérons la sinistralité elle
est très mal mesurée du fait de la
sous-déclaration des maladies
professionnelles comme les actions du
travail et ça c'est un c'est un débat
quelquefois houleux mais en tout cas
tant qu'on mesure pas mieux la
sinistralité dans les entreprises que
soit je le répète en termes d'accident
de travail ou de maladie professionnelle
on ne fera pas d'une bonne prévention ça
c'est non seulement les statistiques
avec lequel vous travaillez et nous on
travaille on considère qu'ils sont qui
sont qui sont faussés ça c'est très
clair pour nous c'est très clair donc
que ce qui est une vraie aussi dynamique
de créer pour que cette sous-déclaration
cesse alors qu'elle soit
institutionnalisée parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est une réalité elle est
institutionnalisée dans moi je l'ai vécu
j'étais suffisamment en entreprise pour
le pour le vivre ou ou aujourd'hui les
entreprises font en sorte de ne pas
déclarer ou de sous-déclarer c'est à
dire pas d'igy enfin de mal déclarer les
actions du travail et ça c'est et ça
c'est un impact énorme sur la prévention
qu'on peut effectuer après dans la dans
les entreprises et puis tout le reste ou
la Cour des comptes vous savez aussi
bien que moi mesures cette
sous-décration en faisant la transfert
de fonds entre la branche ATMP et la
sécurité sociale jouait l'évaluer entre
1 et 2 milliards c'est gigantesque et
donc il y a un moment donné il y a
quelque chose qui va pas donc c'est ça
il faut ça il faut il faut il faut
absolument le résorber c'est tout je je
j'ai envie de parler aussi de l'impact
de l'organisation du travail je trouve
qu'on en parle peut-être pas
suffisamment j'entendais parler du
lève-personne par exemple mais laisse
personne aujourd'hui les femmes qui
s'occupent des des des malades n'utilise
pas pourquoi parce qu'ils ont même pas
le temps il y a une tête pression sur le
temps
que l'utilise pas donc par ce
déchargement parce que un corps humain
c'est aussi c'est plus lourd qu'un sac
de ciment excusez-moi de la comparaison
mais quand un homme on dit l'homme il
peut souplesse mais les femmes qui
doivent soulever des personnes elles ont
un aide personne qui est quelquefois
financé d'ailleurs par la par la branche
mais il n'utilise pas parce qu'ils n'ont
pas le temps ils ont une tête pression
sur les sur leur sur leur
des 10 minutes pour s'occuper d'une
personne on l'a entendu suffisamment on
a entendu suffisamment parler ces
derniers ces derniers mois ces dernières
années donc dans les EHPAD entre autres
le temps n'est pas donné pour bien faire
son travail c'est l'organisation du
travail qui est en cause et qui est à
revoir on pourrait parler des femmes de
ménage qui viennent nettoyer les bureaux
à 5 heures du mat pour que nous on soit
tranquille dans nos bureaux et que on
puisse travailler tranquillement ça
c'est une horreur absolue la CGT
travaille différemment les femmes elles
viennent dans dans les bureaux quand on
y est puis ça fonctionne très bien eux
au moins elles ont des horaires
acceptables et en tout cas pas nocif
pour leur santé
merci beaucoup monsieur Tillot pour la
CGPME merci madame la Présidente je suis
trop respectueux du dialogue social que
je
participe depuis plus de 40 ans pour ne
pas avoir pris le soin de dire que
c'était la majorité des partenaires
sociaux qui depuis plus de 2 ans porté
la prévention et en cela je respectais
l'attitude singulière de la DGT
vous avez parlé madame des postiers des
postiers des facteurs ou des factrices
et je crois que c'est le bel exemple
qui fait qu'une approche de prévention
primaire qui recherche l'innocuité du
poste plutôt que l'adaptation de son
opérateur s'illustre parfaitement
alors à savoir si c'est la lutte des
femmes ou la prévention primaire qui a
obtenu un tel résultat
je me lancerai pas dans ce débat je sais
qu'avec c'est pour ça que je le refuse
et
le temps nous est compté je crois et
mais on peut le reprendre dans d'autres
circonstances quand vous voulez la CGT
vous pour apporter témoignage de ma
grande disponibilité dans le cadre du
dialogue social
je crois que
cette attitude et cet exemple du facteur
elle date pas d'hier je l'ai répété dans
mon propos dès le début du 19e siècle
bien que la prévention soit universelle
et indifférenciée on avait compris que
la physiologie des femmes ne pouvait pas
supporter le port de charge et qui
valent à celui des hommes
et je crois me souvenir qu'au niveau
européen cette différenciation a été
combattue au nom de l'égalité
homme-femme
vous parlez des violences sexuelles
alors ça et ça existe c'est exact nous
n'avons pas répondu à cette question
et nous tenons à dire la CPME à ce titre
participent et à participer tant à la
conception que la diffusion la plus
large de tous les messages de prévention
de ce que nous
regroupons sur ce que nous appelons les
dysfonctionnements relationnels au
travail qui sont des problèmes
essentiels et majeurs
alors c'est vrai que pour les PME cette
situation est d'autant plus compliquée
que les collectivités de travail sont
très réduites et que ces situations
provoquent de véritables séismes dans
l'organisation du travail mais également
du point de vue humain et à ce titre
nous sommes toujours preneurs
et toujours partant pour trouver des
méthodes
définitives et durables dans ce domaine
pour le télétravail pour le télétravail
on voit les limites de cette prévention
des risques professionnels qui est
exclusivement à la charge des employeurs
de ce fait on se trouve dans des
situations de prévention des risques
professionnels qui partagent un domaine
où ils ont autorité le lieu de travail
et celui où n'en en point le domicile
et ça pose des problèmes c'est à dire
conceptuellement nous n'avons pas les
outils pour pouvoir gérer ces deux
domaines dont le code du travail fait
une barrière exclusive
c'est un peu le sens de notre
proposition du MPC mais plus encore de
la relation médecin traitant et médecin
du travail
de tête pour toute façon à pouvoir
disposer des connaissances partagées de
telle sorte que l'on puisse développer
des outils de
prévention adaptée ce n'est pas le cas
il y a des blocages conceptuels de droit
d'ordre juridique qui font
qu'actuellement mais ce n'est pas vrai
que pour la prévention des risques
professionnels c'est vrai pour la
gestion du contrat de travail en
télétravail qui pose des problèmes des
des fractures et des intervalles libres
majeurs et qui nous bloque dans une
approche à la fois cohérente et complète
de
ces problèmes nouveaux tentent en
matière de prévention que
de relations de travail d'une façon plus
générale
merci
monsieur Tillon donc je vais passer la
parole à notre dernière intervenant de
la matinée la rapporteur Annick
merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les représentants
des syndicats désolé j'ai pas pu
entendre vos propos puisque j'étais
retenue à une autre réunion avant mais
je voudrais revenir sur deux trois
points
dans nos que vous avez évoqué madame et
Messieurs des représentants les CPME
la première chose c'est quand vous
parlez de stigmatiques de risque de
stigmatisation
comment est-ce que vous pensez que cette
stigmatisation peut se
révéler au sein des entreprises est-ce
que c'est uniquement j'allais dire pour
celles qui sont en poste par rapport à
leurs collègues par rapport à l'ambiance
générale du travail ou est-ce qu'il y a
un risque aussi à l'embauche
entre un homme et une femme est-ce que
au niveau des chefs d'entreprise il peut
y avoir un frein à l'embauche justement
d'embaucher une femme avec les désordres
qui peuvent éventuellement se manifester
la deuxième chose vous avez parlé aussi
de TMS de prévention alors Monsieur
Perrault je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec vous même si j'ai pas
votre expérience j'ai été longtemps
président d'un conseil d'administration
ou de surveillance d'un EHPAD dans
lequel on a effectivement installé
beaucoup de lèvres malades et qui qui
sont utilisés alors je vais pas faire
une généralisation d'un seul cas mais
les représentants syndicaux qui siégé
dans ce conseil de surveillance
souligné quand même à mieux être pour
les salariés après je suis d'accord avec
vous que c'est des charges considérables
à soulever et par rapport à ça je sais
qu'on met souvent en place et on l'avait
fait aussi des
des formations justement pour aider à
voir les bons gestes les bonnes postures
mais ne pensez-vous pas qu'il serait
judicieux d'utiliser les heures un
certain nombre d'heures d'éducation
physique dans les collèges les lycées
les écoles primaires pour apprendre déjà
aux enfants aux ados les postures pour
soulever parce que si on si on regarde
enfin je sais que moi très longtemps je
soulevé en baissant le dos et pas en
pied en les genoux et je pense que ça
peut aussi être d'apprendre tôt les bons
gestes ça peut servir je pense toute la
vie alors je dis pas qu'il faut pas
adapter les poches du pas qu'il y a pas
des choses à faire mais les simples
postures j'allais dire du quotidien
peuvent aussi soulager un petit peu dans
le monde du travail
voilà en gros
parler merci merci Madame la rapporteur
je vous laisse organiser comme vous le
souhaitez peut-être la CGT qui
souhaitait intervenir et donc ce sera
peut-être les mots de conclusion
puisqu'on va juste
sur la dernière remarque de management
c'est le code du travail dit quand même
il faut adapter le travail à l'homme
alors il faudrait il faudrait rajouter
et là je m'adresse aux législateur
rajouter adapter le travail les neuf
principes généraux de prévention 10 fois
adapter le travail à l'homme pour
rajouter et à la femme
ce serait ce serait ce serait déjà parce
que c'est dans le code du travail j'ai
pas la mémoire des articles et 9
principes généraux de prévention disent
qu'il faut adapter le travail à l'homme
donc former très bien et tout mais oui
aménagé les postes et permettre
permettre de travailler dans des dans
les bonnes conditions et malheureusement
là je alors c'est votre vision de ce
côté-là mais malheureusement beaucoup de
nos représentants disent que ces fameux
lèvres personnes c'est très difficile de
les utiliser parce que encore une fois
j'insiste parce que c'est un c'est
fondamental ils ont pas le temps tout
simplement
parce que censé faire de congé menstruel
on va y revenir dans les semaines qui
viennent vous serez probablement de
nouveau en ce qui concerne les
partenaires sociaux sollicité pour
donner votre avis juste sur un souci que
vous avez qui est celui de la
confidentialité du respect de la vie
privée de la crainte de la
stigmatisation voire même d'un facteur
de
discrimination professionnelle qui
serait dit au fait que l'employeur
serait que ces salariés certaines de ces
salariés
bénéficient on fait l'objet d'un congé
d'un arrêt d'un congé maladie un peu
particulier parce qu'il est à la fois
longue durée et à et à jour aléatoire
voilà et à joignant
nous parce que je nous pensons que le
féminisme la lutte des femmes et des
féministes ont fait beaucoup pour la
prise en compte de la spécificité des
femmes au travail bien entendu avec les
partenaires sociaux n'auraient pas pu y
arriver toute seule mais je vais faire
on toujours cette préoccupation et on
l'a depuis 40 ans quasiment est-ce que
les femmes est-ce qu'il faut dire que
les femmes sont des femmes ou est-ce
qu'il faut dire que les femmes sont des
hommes comme les autres quand elles sont
au travail et on mesure bien à chaque
fois les risques qu'il y a à dire que
les femmes sont des femmes un certain
nombre d'événements sont difficiles à
dissimuler la grossesse
en particulier et on sait bien qu'il y a
qu'on connaît le risque c'est un risque
avéré d'ailleurs en ce qui concerne les
femmes mais on peut faire aussi
l'analyse du fait que globalement les
femmes ont serré les dents et les femmes
ont quand elles sont très massivement
dans le monde du travail
je dis en serrer les dents c'était en
décidé d'être des hommes comme les
autres au travail et de neutraliser au
maximum ce qui était spécifique au fait
d'être une femme et on trouve pas que le
bilan soit particulièrement positif de
cette stratégie là et on pense à
l'inverse que aujourd'hui enfin je pense
parce que je pense qu'il y avait aussi
des débats y compris chez les gens qui
poursuivent les mêmes ambitions que les
miennes et on pense qu'aujourd'hui en
fait il faut que la société assume que
les femmes sont des femmes et quand vous
êtes employeur et que vous avez des
femmes contre 20 et 55 ans il y a une
présomption quasi irréfragable de règles
régulières chez les femmes voilà c'est
une présomption irréfragable toutes les
femmes ont leurs règles et puis après
une deuxième présomption qui est que un
certain nombre d'entre elles sont
affectés
et ce n'est pas en faisant comme si ça
n'existait pas pour les femmes qu'elles
peuvent lever les obstacles et que ça
met sur la voie de l'égalité
professionnelle c'est au contraire en
banalisant en banalisant et en faisant
de cette événement
mensuel de vie un élément que tout le
monde doit partager et pour tout vous
dire j'entends beaucoup de gens en ce
moment dire que on pourrait régler la
question des retraites si les femmes
faisaient des bébés plus de bébés
écoutez que ceux qui disent ça commence
déjà par se dire que la première des
conditions pour que les femmes fassent
des bébés c'est qu'elles soient
pas affecté dans leur volonté d'égalité
par le fait de faire des bébés
et d'avoir une biologie enfin une
physiologie spécifique et différente de
celle des hommes voilà c'est juste pour
votre pour soumettre ça votre réflexion
sur
choisir entre arbitrer entre le silence
ou
l'affirmation merci Madame la rapporteur
donc on va poursuivre ce tour de table
pour en réponse à l'intervention de
Madame Jacquemet et donc ce sera vos
mots de conclusion aussi puisque leur
tourne je remercie merci beaucoup de
consacrer du temps à ces sujets mon
propos il serait de dire plusieurs
choses d'abord
il y a souvent besoin d'un équilibre en
toute chose pour à la fois balancer les
les risques éventuels et en même temps
faire exister le sujet et mon propos a
toujours été de communiquer et il est
important de d'investir beaucoup sur la
prévention primaire je crois que ça
c'est vraiment un point
[Musique]
il y a eu beaucoup de chemin déjà
franchis sur ces sujets là maintenant si
jamais assez on sait bien que il y a des
dimensions qui sont pas faciles à
corriger mais il faut engager les
entreprises et plus il y aura de la
communication et de l'accompagnement
plus on y arrivera et dans
l'accompagnement je mets à la fois
toutes les efforts de prise de
connaissance mais évidemment il y a
besoin d'accompagnement financier se
sont bien les fonds de prévention
je voudrais rajouter un autre point
qui est que en fait
cette prévention primaire elle est
souvent beaucoup citée mais pas
forcément appliquée et s'il y a un
mouvement plus large que celui au sein
des entreprises
et notamment par rapport à ce
télétravail donc à mon avis nous n'avons
pas vu tous les conséquences tous les
sujets et tous les enjeux et bien on
pourra je pense aller aller plus loin
donc mon point c'est prévention primaire
mais ne regardons pas que le premier
cercle regardons plus largement et puis
je pense que en effet il y a des
expressions qui disent que
il ne faudrait pas discriminer parce
qu'il peut y avoir un risque de
discrimination et puis en même temps il
y a d'autres expressions qui disent mais
pourquoi afficher que les femmes sont
plus vulnérables
alors qu'elles peuvent occuper les mêmes
postes que les salariés masculins à
travailler égal bien sûr et en même
temps on sait bien que la nature fait
que nous sommes différents et c'est
probablement une grande richesse et que
il s'agit de sensibiliser les uns et les
autres pour que le regard des uns et des
autres puissent être un regard éduqué et
un regard qui permet le respect et le
travail dans des collectifs qui sont des
collectifs harmonieux et respectueux
parce que l'entreprise avant tout ce
sont des collectifs fait de femmes et
d'hommes et je pense que ça c'est
quelque chose de très important merci de
votre attention
merci madame la Présidente je vais
essayer de en concluant de répondre et à
Madame Jacquemet à Madame rossignol
la CPME estime que avec le recul
maintenant des 20 30 dernières années
et constate une évolution majeure des
mentalités au regard des femmes et du
travail j'en veux pour preuve
l'ouverture de nouveaux postes à leur
activité professionnelle qui aurait été
impensable il y a encore 10 ans ou 20
ans
je voudrais rappeler le propos avec
lequel j'ai commencé à savoir qu'un
patron embauche au procède à
l'embauchage plutôt d'un salarié
et je ne sais pas si les femmes sont des
hommes je ne sais pas si les femmes sont
des femmes mais je sais que les salariés
sont soit des hommes soit des femmes
très bien donc c'était votre mode
conclusion j'imagine
vous souhaitiez également intervenir
madame Verzeletti
non c'est bon bah écoutez si nous avons
monsieur oui tout à fait monsieur perron
une contribution écrivain vous souhaitez
rapide
nous sommes le 10 11 le 11 11 très bien
nous sommes le 11 mai donc je pense
d'ici la fin du mois maximum voilà je
donc si la fin du mois et bien entendu
cette possibilité de nous envoyer des
éléments par mail s'adresse à tous les
intervenants de cette table ronde de ce
matin il me reste à remercier mesdames
les rapporteurs à vous remercier
mesdames et messieurs pour vos
interventions on a vu quelques
divergences mais c'est aussi ça la
richesse d'une table ronde de
positionnement et nous allons poursuivre
avec les rapporteurs les quatre
rapporteurs puisque Marie Pierre Ricci
était excusée ce matin ce travail et
donc quelques semaines les rapporteurs
rendront leur
le train le travail de compte-rendu et
des propositions forcément que vous ne
manquerez pas j'imagine de regarder avec
attention donc merci à vous tous je vous
souhaite une excellente journée et merci
pour cette participation matinale à
cette table ronde et bien entendu
j'associe l'administration du Sénat qui
nous accompagne et qui est aux manettes
de l'organisation merci bonne journée